You wake up and you're freaking excited.
You're pumped. Your heart's racing.
You're ready to get on with the day.
See, it's New Year's and you and your
buddies made a commitment to each other
that this is the year you transform
yourselves. You all got a gym membership
to the dungeon that has the old school
bodybuilding equipment. You all splurged
on a training program from your favorite
online coach. You guys are leaving no
stone on turn, no gains on the table.
You've budgeted for meals. You've
budgeted for coaching. And now you've
budgeted for supplements. And today, the
day before you hit your first workout,
you and your buddies are going to swing
by your local supplement store to stock
up on vital muscle building potions.
Now, you guys walk in, there's loads of
shiny [__] on the shelf. There's boxes
and tubs and baggies. Some of it looks
sparkly and whimsical. Some of it is
made to look like actual
pharmaceuticals. And all of it promises
to be the best to make you the best.
Now, here's the uncomfortable truth.
Almost all of it is complete [__]
Despite all of the internet tier lists,
despite the recommendations from
friends, even the things you see your
favorite bodybuilders using on
Instagram, and certainly despite
whatever nonsense promises they slap on
the label, the supplement industry has
an incredibly long history of
underdelivering. Low regulation has led
to scandals. There's risk of
contamination. There's labels that make
promises they just can't deliver on. And
there's a marketing system that makes
sure you spend the most money on the
thing that is the least useful to you.
I'm here to give you a rundown of the
most popular gym supplements. But to do
that, we have to understand the industry
and how it's structured. It exists to
exploit your ambition and your anxiety.
We're going to talk about all the
[__] that's out there, what people
are spending their money on, and what
they should be doing with it instead.
Horse weights require having horse hips.
And when you've got cakes like a short
stack, a comfortable fit is hard to
find. Barbell Apparel is the only brand
that's up to the job. And I'm so adamant
that you try these shorts that I
actually went to the higherups and said,
"Hey guys, I need to hook my people up
with some shorts. What can I do?" And
they finally caved in and said, "You
know what? Just to get you off our back,
we're going to hook them up with a free
pair of shorts with any purchase over
$99 as long as they use your code,
Brmley. Supplies are limited, so go now.
Now, most know by now that the
supplement industry benefits from low
regulation in the United States.
Supplements are classified as foods, not
drugs. And that means the threshold of
proof for both safety and the claims
that they make is impossibly low. Like
bottom of the ocean low. Now, if you're
a CEO that is running such a company,
you're going to realize a very clear
truth. The only reason that anybody in
their right mind would ever spend a dime
on one of your products is because they
think it's going to deliver a tangible
outcome. So, we have a business that has
a high incentive to make people believe
their stuff is going to make them better
in the gym, and we have an economic
environment with extraordinarily low
checks and balances. So, to the absolute
surprise of no one, bad behavior would
ensue. In 2001, the International
Olympic Committee conducted a
contamination study of supplements.
Researchers tested 634 supplements from
13 different countries. 15% contained
anabolic steroids that were not listed
on the label. These were not trace
amounts for manufacturing
cross-contamination. These were
substantial dosages of undisclosed
steroids in supplements pulled off the
shelf from major markets. Now, 2001 was
during the pro hormone craze where
designer steroids were being made and
sold over-the-counter. And because they
existed at your local supplement shop,
and because they were taken as a pill as
opposed to being injected with a needle,
they were able to shed much of the
stigma that this was the same as
injecting steroids. Now, in the same
era, supplements like hydroxyut and
Zenadryine would populate the shelves at
your local grocery store. They would
promote rapid fat loss through their key
ingredient, a fedrine. And I think
anybody who played sports in the early
2000s has at least one experience with
drinking a red line before practice and
then trying to survive through the
summer heat while your heart spasms
inside your chest. Now, because of its
intense effects, it would lead to the
death of both an MLB pitcher and an NFL
lineman, along with a few hundred other
deaths that were reportedly linked to
the use. So in 2004, the FDA would step
up and ban pro hormones as well as the
use of a fedrine. However, demand would
not go away. About a decade later, the
popular pre-workout supplement Jack 3D,
which contained DMAA, would dominate the
industry. Now, DMAA was a stimulant that
was marketed as a natural geranium
extract, but evidence suggested that it
was actually a synthetic amphetamine
analog. Makes it seem less funny when
you get pre-workouts that are given
names like angel dust. It would be a
matter of time before it was linked to
heart attacks, strokes, and deaths among
military personnel, leading the US
military to ban it from bases and the
FDA to eventually force it off the
market. It would seem the supplements
that actually behave like the magic
muscle potions they claim they are have
historically been too good to be true.
So instead of blurring the lines of
safety to deliver results, companies
today settle on intensely misleading
marketing for supplements that do a
whole hell of a lot less. Case in point,
testosterone boosters. Common
ingredients in these boosters include
tribulus terrestrius, ashwagandha,
fenugreek, and deaspartic acid. The
claim is that it boosts testosterone,
which should build muscle and get you
stronger and you know do all the other
steroidy things that testosterone
typically does. But of course, you feel
better about doing it this way because
it's quote unquote natural. Now, the
reality of testosterone boosters isn't
that everybody's actually taking
steroids. It's really that they just
don't do a damn thing. A scientific
review of commercial testosterone
boosters found that 90% claimed to raise
testosterone, but only about 25%
even have ingredients with any actual
evidence for doing so. Almost 23
contained ingredients with no evidence
at all. 10% of them actually had
ingredients that were shown to lower
testosterone. As if that wasn't bad
enough, consider the actual research
that they were citing. The majority of
studies on these ingredients weren't
done in humans. They were shown in rats
or in cell cultures. Even the human
studies showing slight increases in
testosterone rarely translated to
measurable gains. The fact is that test
boosters exist because men's
testosterone anxiety is extremely
marketable. It's a pretty simple
playbook. You talk about some of the
problems that men tend to face. Fatigue,
aging, low libido. describe it as a
symptom of low tea and then you sell
them the solution and something they can
pick up over the counter at their local
GNC. The supplements almost never
deliver, but the marketing almost always
does.
This brings us to kind of an interesting
point about supplements in the first
place that describes the relationship
between the consumer and the supplier.
Anytime you're taking something for the
express purpose of getting bigger or
stronger, there's going to be a question
of cheating that pops up. You have
sporting organizations that have worked
double time to combat unfair advantages
and limit health risks. But besides
that, there are many lifters who don't
compete who are concerned about their
progress somehow being seen as invalid
if they are found to have gotten it the
easy way. So when you go to the
supplement store fully prepared to spend
a few hundred on a month's worth of
supplies, what exactly is driving the
excitement as you pull them off the
shelf, set them on the counter, and pull
out your credit card? You're excited.
You're eager. you can't wait to mix it
together to get the results to go hit
the gym to actually get those gains. But
if it gives you a boost, is that still
taking a shortcut? The truth is the
lines aren't exactly clear. We think we
have a clear idea of peeds as it's often
just a shorthand for hormones. That's
easy enough to identify. Has a big
impact on the body. There's identifiable
health risks and an obvious unfair
advantage. But consider the other
compounds that have been problematic in
the past. Caffeine was banned by the IOC
between 1984 and 2004 if it exceeded a
certain blood concentration. By the OC
standards, any one of you that's taken a
full scoop of pre-workout is cheating.
Athletes have been banned because of
substances in asthma and cold
medications and even recreational
substances like marijuana and even at
one point beer. That's right. The first
athlete to fill a drug test for a
performance-enhancing substance was
actually a Swedish pentathlete in 1968
who drank two beers before the shooting
event. According to the IOC, you will
not calm your nerves. Even today,
there's a meme of new lifters referring
to creatine as a steroid because when
you're new and you see something that
says it's going to make you stronger,
what's the actual difference? That's not
to say there isn't one, but the lines
aren't established by a clean principle.
And this creates a real paradox for
supplement users. There's an obvious
desire to get their money's worth, but
also to feel good about it, like they're
not taking a shortcut or getting an
unfair boost. Consider the category of
testosterone boosters. If they
legitimately raise your testosterone
like they advertise, would they
eventually merit a ban? Could they be
labeled as a peed? Would it be different
because something made from an herb is
natural? Would the health effects
matter? Would your standards change
depending on if it was a competitive
setting or not? Here's what the industry
knows. There is in fact a sweet spot
between something being totally natural
and this is clearly
performance-enhancing. And that gray
zone is where supplement companies live.
It's where they build brands. It's where
they play off of your ambition and
anxiety. It's where they sell you a
natural solution that might actually end
up getting you banned. Or it's where
they sell you a $60 tub that just
doesn't do anything at all.
Branch chain amino acids were and still
are a staple of the typical supplement
buyer. These are the building blocks of
proteins that were once thought to be
the key to muscle protein synthesis. And
there was a time where you couldn't walk
into a corporate gym without seeing some
noob low-level lifter wearing a rich
Piana t-shirt and carrying around his
plastic jug of bright green branch chain
amino acid [__] Research
consistently shows that adequate protein
intake renders the use of BCAAs
obsolete. There's like no reason to take
them. People will still give French
cases for when they might give a
benefit, but even that isn't going to
reach a clinically significant
difference. Meaning, you're not going to
observe a difference that is actually
worth the cost. It is just flavored
water that you're paying for, but hey,
at least you're hydrated. BCAAs get a
solid one out of five.
Next up, we have one of the bigger
tempoles of the supplement industry, and
that is preworkout. Every fitness expo
you go to, you can be guaranteed that
twothirds of the booths are going to be
people hawking their preworkout. Modern
pre-workouts typically don't rely on
methamphetamine isomers. Instead, they
just rely on an absolute [__] ton of
caffeine because, as all energy drinks
figured out, if you cram 300 milligs of
caffeine into a single serving, the
people that drink it feel really, really
good. They also put other things in beta
alanine, citrine, creatine, amino acids.
Some of this stuff doesn't do a damn
thing that's noticeable. Some of it is
to give you a tingly sensation so that
you actually feel like it's doing
something. But the truth is, the
caffeine is the heavy hitter. I remember
going up to the hide booth at the LA Fit
Expo and the rep specifically said,
"Let's face it, the 400 milligrams of
caffeine is the key ingredient here.
Caffeine blocks adenosine receptors. It
reduces perceived fatigue. It
consistently improves performance. And
this is why it was banned for a period
of time in the Olympics. Now, you can't
deny that preworkout gets you jacked up.
But the question is, is the juice worth
the squeeze? A 30 serving tub of
pre-workout with 300 milligs of caffeine
per serving is going to cost up to 50
bucks these days. You can literally walk
into your grocery store right now and
get a box of generic caffeine pills for
like eight bucks and it's going to do
the exact same thing minus the tingly
fingers. The math here is not
complicated. Now, pre-workouts aren't
completely useless. Slamming 400 millig
of caffeine in a single swallow is going
to make you feel like King Kong, and
that can make some workouts go off like
a treat. But I'm going to say that I
don't know very many competitors or
long-term successful lifters who lean on
super massive amounts of caffeine in
order to get their workouts in. However,
over the years, I've known a lot of
people who have had it spike their
anxiety, had it ruin their sleep, who
have convinced themselves that they
actually need it to get a good workout.
The main reason I hate it is because
it's ruined more workouts than it helps.
Like, don't get me wrong, it was cool
getting twacked out on Jack 3D in 2010
and tearing through a three-hour chest
and bicep workout, but if you want to
have one of the worst experiences of
your life, take any one of these brands
today that have 400 migs of caffeine in
them and try to do a high volume squat
workout. Bring some ibuprofen for the
massive tension headache you're about to
get. And bring a puke bucket. I give
pre-workout like a 2 and 1/2 out of
five. Guys, if you want to hit the holy
trifecta of gains, the size, the
strength, and of course the clout, you
need a program that checks the biggest
boxes. Not only does it use the best
time-tested movements that you are
actually likely to stick to and improve
on, but it includes a logical
progression that is based on my most
popular programs. These are programs
that have gotten rave reviews from
people that literally just ran the
template. Base strength AI uses three of
the most proven templates pulled from
the principles of some of the biggest,
strongest men in history that have been
used for over a century. The workouts
are fun, intuitive, there's a logical
progression, but it does take it up a
notch because it personalizes the
workouts to you. As you get bigger,
stronger, more advanced, it becomes
harder to tick those numbers forward,
and you can't get by not adjusting your
workouts to your own particular
tolerances. And most people get an
online coach to take care of that for
them to the tune of $200 to $300 a
month. And the rest of the people just
never figure it out to begin with. So,
if you're wondering why you start every
training cycle super excited only to get
several weeks in, feel brittle,
overtrained, tired, disillusioned, like
you're just a dodgeball in the program
is the side of a building, then you need
direction that update your training
minute to minute, daytoday, week to week
based on your immediate feedback. Bay
Strength AI takes the guesswork out of
training and it does what only an online
coach can do, which is personalize the
program to you at a tenth of the cost.
Yes, a tenth of the cost. So, jump on
the heart and soul of old school
training. It's my programming, but it is
your program and you cannot get that
anywhere else. Hit up basrength.com
today to get started on your gains. Next
up, we have protein powder. Now, protein
powder is really just food and it
generally does what food does. Every jug
is going to give some long amino acid
profile to try to set itself apart like
that [__] matters to anyone anywhere.
It absolutely doesn't, but they're going
to leave out the fact that it's less
nutritionally dense than regular ass
food. Now, this isn't really a problem
unless you're on the velocity diet. Does
anybody remember that gem? The whole
premise of the diet was to get shredded
as quick as possible by consuming
nothing but protein shakes for 30 days.
Now, the flavor profile of protein
powders can range from the milk from a
bowl of Fruity Pebbles to the cardboard
box that the Fruity Pebbles came in. But
even the offensively cheap stuff can be
a blessing if you're just tired of hking
down chicken and tuna six times a day. I
mean, there were diets where I didn't
care if it was just blended sand. Just
let me suffer for the 5 seconds it takes
to get that down. I'll even lick the
little bit on the cap when you pop it
open because I just don't want to deal
with the monotony and the tired jaw as I
sit there and try to power my way
through another dry ass chicken breast
for 20 minutes. Now, that is the entire
selling point of protein powders. They
don't do anything special. It's really
just convenience. So, the important
thing is to figure out how much money
you have in your budget so that you can
buy the primo stuff that doesn't taste
like a curdled Splenda packet. Now,
aside from flavor, you also want to
consider how sensitive your tummy is.
Every powder-based protein I've ever
taken has done something weird to my
stomach. Whey and casein come from milk,
so there's the lactose issue, but you
also have to be aware of the low carb
proteins these days that use sugar
alcohols to give the flavor. Sorbidol,
maltitol, xylitol, arythritol. These
could all be associated with explosive
gas and diarrhea. But of all the
proteins I've ever tried, the worst
offender, the one that made me feel like
I swallowed a little Mike Tyson and he
was trying to punch his way out was
plant-based proteins. Both pea and soy
proteins are just egregious. 10 out of
10. Do not recommend. Now, of course,
everybody is different, but you have to
ask if the convenience of a shake is
worth the gut issues caused by something
that is more expensive per gram of
protein than a regular ass chicken
breast or a can of tuna. I see protein
powder as a minor convenient, something
that's not likely to be used year round.
It's often used as a crutch for poor
meal planning, though it certainly won't
make up for it, and it quickly becomes
obsolete once you get meal prep down
anyways. But maybe some of you like
suffering through rainbow flavored
sweeteners. Protein powder is a three
and a half out of five. It serves its
purpose. It's certainly not going to
make you worse, but it is far far from
essential. And then lastly, we have what
I'm going to call the granddaddy of
supplements because it's probably the
only one that does exactly what it
claims to do. Creatine monohydrate.
Creatine works by increasing
phosphocreatine stores in the muscle
which itself causes the muscles to swell
and that allows faster ATP regeneration
during short intense efforts. Just
imagine you're driving your car and you
use up the gas and it turns into smog
and you add something that combined with
the smog to make more gas. That's kind
of what's going on here. What that means
is that you get a bit more staying power
and explosive activities and that means
that for the same weight plate on the
PEDex stack, you're going to be able to
crank out a few more reps. Now, there's
also been some buzz that claimed
increasing dosage from five to more than
20 grams per day can actually aid in
cognitive function and even offset the
effects of sleep deprivation. Now, that
might sound expensive, but it's not.
Creatine is like stupidly cheap. Like,
it doesn't make sense how cheap it is.
So, because it's safe, it does exactly
what it claims, and it's cheap as hell,
I give creatine a five out of five. If
you have a month or two of just gnarly
training on the horizon and you want to
get the most out of it, it is absolutely
worth spending 10 bucks on a jug that's
going to last you the whole run because
the boost isn't just predictable. It's
actually significant. Now, that doesn't
mean you're out of the woods, though.
There's a problem with creatine, and
that's that monohydrate is super
generic, and it makes it hard for
companies to stand out. And as a result,
many have tried a lot of just gimmicky
[__] to try to get you to pay more
for their weak ass twist on creatine.
Consider that dare Celtech. I got my
very first stretch marks on my pecs as a
13-year-old lad who had his older
brother buying him Celtech every month
in preparation for football. Now,
Celtech had a couple of key ingredients.
It had creatine, but it also had
alphaloic acid and just a [__] ton of
sugar, which they claimed helped the
creatine load faster. And maybe it did.
Or maybe just consuming 70 gram of sugar
a pop is actually pretty freaking
anabolic. But the thing is, Celtech was
expensive as hell. The creatine is dirt
cheap and sugar is everywhere. I mean, I
would have been better off just drinking
a Coke. And we've had other turns on it.
We've had creatine hydrochloride. We've
had cre alkaline and on and on. All
making completely baseless claims that
they were going to be the next big thing
or that they did something better faster
in a more potent manner than monohydrate
and just none of it's true. The $10 jug
of monohydrate that lasts you like a
year is always going to be your best
bet. Now, since we have a lay of the
land of the most common supplements out
there, let's look at where people are
actually spending their money. Protein
powder dominates the industry with close
to $30 billion in sales. Protein is
obviously necessary to grow, and powder
is useful, so this isn't so surprising.
But the next big chunk of spend is
preworkout at 22 billion. People are
addicted to caffeine all over the world
for a reason. It makes you function
better. It makes you feel good. And I
wouldn't be surprised if the Superman
sensation of being on loads of
stimulants wasn't the singular thing
that was driving pre-workout sales. But
we've already established that this
doesn't really have any essential
function in your training. Below that,
we have branch chain amino acids and
testosterone boosters. And this
illustrates the problem clearly. Big
sales, [__] product. You would think
the entire working force in the United
States was currently going through BUDS
training with the speed at which they
will purchase items that have recovery
slapped on the front. I didn't know this
whole nation was so underreovered. And
testosterone boosters sell because
they're marketed aggressively to
insecurities. There's the fear of
leaving gains on the table, the fear of
aging, the fear of not doing enough. The
product doesn't actually have to work,
but the anxiety is enough to get you to
buy the product. But then there's
creatine. Creatine tastes like nothing.
It comes in a generic bag. It's dirt
cheap. It gives noticeable improvements
in a short period of time. However,
because the effect is delayed and
because the margins are poor, it makes
up a small fraction of the cost in
sales. This describes the supplement
industry in a nutshell. The fact that
preworkout almost gets as much in sales
is just so impossibly stupid. Especially
when you consider that creatine, which
is by far the most proven and most coste
effective supplement in existence, gets
the smallest share of the market behind
useless ass branch chains and
testosterone boosters.
So, what should you actually do? While I
can say yes, there are some use cases
for these items, I don't think the
benefit of potentially trying to get
that use case out of them is worth the
absolute shitow of engaging with the
supplement industry at all. My
recommendation to all new lifters is to
do what I do. Pretend that the
supplement industry doesn't exist. There
is not a single aspect of training that
hinges on your access to supplements.
But engaging with the industry will give
you FOMO. It will feed off your anxiety
and eventually they will convince you to
spend money that was better left in your
pocket. Walking through a GNC is no
different than walking through a Vegas
casino. Most of the products aren't
going to do a thing to make you better.
Every label you read is likely to
involve misleading info, and the
contents of the tub are likely to be
priced absurdly high for what it could
potentially ever do for your training.
So, that's all I got for today, guys.
Let me know what you think. Thanks so
much for watching. Till next time, this
is Brmley. I'll see you.